[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à toutes et à tous
je suis très heureuse de vous retrouver
sur LCP pour un nouveau numéro de maman
j'ai arrêté l'avion consacré cette fois
à la mer notre mer à tous et pourtant la
grande bleue n'a jamais été aussi pillée
peluée profanée profané c'est le mot
sachant que l'océan est sacré il absorbe
près d'un tiers de nos émissions de CO2
et régule le climat autant dire que
notre avenir est directement indexé à sa
santé or plus on le dégrade et moins il
joue son rôle de thermostat planétaire
réchauffement pollution sur pêche
acidification algu rien Raphaël rien ne
va plus oui à l'échelle de la planète
nous prélevons chaque année 90 millions
de tonnes de poisson crustacé ou
coquillage ce qui fait en moyenne par
français 24 kg par an une consommation
qui a doublé depuis les années 60 autre
chiffre fort on estime que l'activité
humaine a divisé par 3 voire 5 la
quantité de poissons dans les océans et
même par 10 sur les régions littorales
l'aquaculture en pleine explosion ne
change pas grand-chose à l'affaire pour
nourrir le poid poisson d'élevage on
pêche du poisson sauvage et en effet
plus la demande monte plus les océans se
vident avec une pêche toujours plus
intensive plus industrialisé et plus
subventionné au détriment de la
biodiversité des écosystèmes et des
petits pêcheurs qui boivent la tasse
alors comment protéger l'océant quand
les aires marines protégé non de
protéger que le nom et que la pêche
industrielle a toujours le vent dans le
dos c'est toute la question au fait
maman j'arrête
l'avion
[Musique]
pour en parler la lauréade du prix GM
2018 l'équivalent du Nobel pour
l'environnement la 1 investie CLA
nouviant fondatrice de Bloom l'ONG qui
donne des cauchemars au lobby de
l'espoir au petits pêcheurs et du filart
tordre au politique ça tombe bien l'
représentant l'eurodéputé et président
de la commission pêche au Parlement
européen pierre carleskind et là on
duplexe pour lui répondre et pour nous
éclairer un économiste de la
biodiversité le chercheur et professeur
d'économie écologique à agroparitetech
et à l'université pariscley Harold
Levrel bonjour à tous les trois avant de
vous donner la parole je vous propose
une immersion dans le monde de la pêche
et des poissons d'élevage plus les
océans se vident plus on cherche des
alternatives plutôt que de réguler la
pêche ou chercher a reconstituer des
écosystèmes sains on affine nos
techniques de pêche toujours plus
agressives et on mise sur l'aquaculture
la solution à la pénurie pour certains
mais sous nouvel eldorado est loin
d'être neutre le tout oppose c'est un
reportage des guizo et Ibar
àbar lo tuud dit en Bretagne il est 10h
du
matin sur son petit chalutier de 8,50
Jonathan firmain rentre d'une nuit
entière de
pêche avec un bien maigre
butin normalement il faudrait rentrer
allez avec minimum le minimum 40 kg 40
50 kg serait bien mais là là ça paye pas
le
gasoil avec son filet de 6 m Jonathan
visait des dorades Royal l'un des
poissons vendu le plus cher à la crier
entre 20 et 25 € le
kilo il n'en a attrapé qu'une donc ça
c'est la dorade Royal on la reconnait
avec la tache jaune
là après ça c'est la la dorade grise le
grisé bon elle est pas très grosse mais
bon ça c'est le bar qui fait partie
aussi des des poissons de luxe on va
direoi
là c'est archi nul là il y
a si
poissons aussi bien avec le même nombre
de filets j'aurais pu rentrer avec 500
kg comme là aujourd'hui avec TR
poissons si poissons pour 18 heur de
pêche pour Jonathan le problème ce sont
les chalutiers géants qui ratissent les
mers
le poisson qui pêche bon ça ça fait
partie de la nourriture de ce que nous
on recherche et puis bon B eux c'est
c'est pour faire des les 3/4 peut-être
ou la moitié c'est pour nourrir du
poisson d'élevage il pensent que la
venir dans l'élevage mais bon quand
compare le goût d'un poisson d'élevage
avec un poisson sauvage il y a pas photo
quoi certes le prix sera plus
intéressant mais c'est tout en France
métropolitaine la pêche artisanale
représente 70 % des navires mais
seulement 22 % des captures la pêche
industrielle se taille la part du
[Musique]
lion et aujourd'hui les mers se meurent
plus de 34 % des stocks marins mondiaux
sont surexploités c'est trois fois plus
que dans les années 70 les chalutiers
géants vident les océans de leurs
ressources pour nourrir une population
qui consomme deux fois plus de poissons
qu'il y a 50 ans la pêche artisanale
elle déplore sa disparition programmée
et les fermes d'élevage de poisson sont
souvent vu comme une solution à la
surpêche tandis que les scientifiques
demandent à ce que 30 % des océans soi
protégés d'ici à 2030 nos modèles de
pêche et d'élevage de poisson sont-ils
soutenables de visions s'opposent
olivier lenezet est président du Comité
national des pêches maritimes et des
élevages marins et Didier Gascuel est
professeur en écologie marine à
l'Institut de Rennes on doit être fier
de notre pêche française aujourd'hui la
protection de la ressource elle a été
faite maintenant il faut protéger le
pêcheur la ressource elle est en mauvais
état aujourd'hui clairement l'abondance
de la plupart des espèces pêchées à des
niveaux faibles on a déjà vidé l'océan
d'une partie de de ces
poissons l'ONG shepardd sillonne les
mers pour documenter cette pêche
industrielle en décembre dernier
présidamia SM L et des militants sont
allés traquer des chalutiers géants au
large de Boulogne
surmer on est devant
le arvez à voir peu démesure du
bateau dans un filet comme
celui bateau peut remonter l'équivalent
de la nourriture de 30000 en un coup de
filetnorme c'est une machine de guerre
ce gigantesque navire est capable de
prélever 250 tonnes de poisson en une
seule journée une pêche miraculeuse
qu'un pêcheur artisanal atteindrait en 5
ans
est deè
dem en l'espace d'une semaineer affirme
avoir comptabilisé ne chalutiers comme
celui-ci dans la Manche dont si dans les
E iale française soit à moins de 22 km
des côtes nous retrouvons sa présidente
en Bretagne à son retour de mer avec le
vidéaste de l'association Tangui le
digou la plupart des gens on s'imagine
pas en fait la démesure de ces bateaux
et puis surtout le fait qu' finalement
il pêche très très près de la côte dans
les eaux territoriales dans les aires
marines protégé et il pêche des
quantités astronomiques de de poisson
une pêche qui n'est pas illégale même
dans les airs
[Musique]
protégés impressionant c'est ainsi que
47% de ces navires industriels pêch dans
ces air marine pourtant mise en place
pour préserver l'écosystème
marin curieuse législation de plus alors
que la France annonce protéger plus de
30 % de ses eau seul
0,005
le sont réellement d'après l'association
de protection de la mer
Bloom c'est beau enfin c'est beau c'est
beau et c'est terrible à la
fois les oiseaux marins ils sont
clairement victimes de la surpêche alors
soit par des captures accidentelles soit
parce que en fait B on a des navires qui
pêchent beaucoup trop et donc ça rend
leur capacité à s'alimenter de plus en
plus difficile l'océan c'est pas un un
hangar avec des stocks qui sont
cloisonnés délimités tout est
interdépendant tout est connecté les
espèces elles interagissent les unes
avec les autres et il y a encore pire
figurez-vous le chalu de fond qui racle
les fonds marins rien ne lui échappe et
il est lesté par des poids pesant
parfois plusieurs tonnes les avancées
sur le chalu sont fondamentales on a
allégé le matériel ils son pas dans des
zones où il y a des Correau où il y a
des écosystèmes marins vulnérables donc
les chalutiers aujourd'hui de fond ne
travaillent pas dans des zones sensibles
inconvénient c'est qu'il est pas
sélectif il ramasse tout sur son passage
or une pêche vraiment durable c'est une
pêche dans laquelle on ajuste le
prélèvement on dit tant de telle espèce
tant de tel autre on fait une pêche
chirurgicale en ajustant exactement le
chalu ne le permet pas il ramasse
tout le secteur de la pêche a bien
compris qu'il devait faire des efforts
c'est ainsi qu'ont été lancés des labels
censé représenter une pêche
durable dans ce supermarché de Fontenet
sous-bois en Île de France les poissons
français sont mis en avant par le label
Pavillon
France sur sa plancha l'animatrice Safia
a choisi des produits qui ont mauvaise
réputation allons-y messieurs dames
n'hésitez pas aujourd'hui dégustation
sur nos produits Pavillon France le but
vendre le label et attirer les clients
vers des poissons moins connus pour
diversifier leur
consommation car dans le monde près de
35 % des ressources de la mer sont
surexploités et en Méditerranée ce
chiffre grimpe à 73 %. alors celui-ci
c'est la vieille en dégustation et vous
avez celui-ci c'est le filet de Haran
voors alors j'ai mis que du sel du
poivre sur un filet d'huile d'olive
allez-y laissez-vous tenter vous
connaissez un petit peu nos produits non
alors c'est aussi de mag responsable
Pavillon France voilà c'est une pêche
responsable merci c'est très bon c'est
c'est très bon problème toujours selon
l'association Bloom le fonctionnement
des labels et autres certifications tend
à privilégier les flottes de pêche
industriel nous avons droit à 8 kg de
poisson par an nous en mangeons 24 nous
en mangeons trois fois notre dose donc
quand les consommateurs me demandent
qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire en matière de
produit de la mer mon premier conseil
c'est de commencer par leur dire vous
devez consommer moins de poisson il est
important de la diversité d'espèces de
manger aussi des poissons de saison
c'est ça qu'il faut aussi dire aux
Français et aux Françaises manger
français qu'il viennent d'ici ou
d'ailleurs le saumon est le poisson
favori des Français le pays en est le
deuxième consommateur mondial avec
presque 3 kg avallé par personne et par
an le plus souvent issu de ferme
d'élevage nous sommes à ISIN surmer en
Normandie avec Pascal goumin voilà à
quoi ressemble une ferme qu colle saumon
de France produit 240 tonnes de poisson
chaque année ici 4 bassins de 850 m CB
d'eau salé sont en fonctionnement
continu en fin d'élevage on peut avoir
dans chacun des bassins 60 tonnes de
poisson en maximum donc ça dépend de la
taille c'est pour ça que comme nous on
les pousse pas jusqu'au bout en réalité
si vous considérez des poissons d'un kg
ça vous fait au maximum 60000 poissons
ils ne sont destinés à une phase de
prégrossissement pour être ensuite
introduit en mer dans la ferme marine de
l'entreprise pour le patron cette
production surterre a beaucoup
d'avantages en ayant les systèmes en se
c'est pour ça que ça voit le jour un
petit peu partout dans le monde c'est le
seul endroit où on peut monitorer tous
les paramètres pour assurer les
conditions optimales d'élevage et de
survie les saumons sauvages se
nourrissent principalement de petits
poissons de CR crustacé ou de crevettes
ici ils n'ont droit qu'à des
croquettes nous nos granulés ils vont
être constitués principalement de farine
de poisson nous on est parti du principe
que voilà le le poisson devait manger du
poisson genre des sardines des petits
poisson minotiers en fait qui vont être
capturés principalement sur dans les
eaux du Chili et pour produire 1 kg de
poisson d'élevage il faudrait compter
entre 2 et 5 kg de poisson sauvag est-ce
bien une
écologiquement compatible à la surpêche
c'est une idée je pense absolument
totalement fausse pour les élever il
faut leur donner de la farine de poisson
et cette farine de poisson il faut donc
aller la pêcher en mer donc chaque fois
qu'on mange un saumon on ne résout pas
les problèmes de surpêche on les aggrave
ces poissons sont pêchés par des grandes
flottilles industrielles généralement
dans les pays du Sud donc on pille les
ressources du Sud pour nourrir les
saumons des riches industriel qui ne
sont pas prês de s'arrêter en Gironde
par exemple l'entreprise pur salmon
prévoit de produire 10000 tonnes de
saumons par an c'est 40 fois plus que la
ferme que nous venons de visiter ce
terrain deviendrait le plus grand
élevage intensif aquacole terrestre du
[Musique]
monde Bordeaux en décembre dernier
Esther Dufor représentante de
l'association au secours
agisson a donné rendez-vous à ses
militantes pour une séance de tractage
contre ce méga projet d'usine de saumon
donner un peu plus si vous voulez donner
quelques mot sur le projet bien
expliquer que c'est un projet qui a
l'échelle locale donc c'est vraiment
chez nous en Gironde et bien rappeler
que ce qui pose problème c'est la taille
les 10000 tonnes la densité de poisson
c'est 70 kg de saumon par mètre cube
d'eau et les du coup il se touchent les
les saumons il se blaissent ils se font
mal il y a du cannibalisme voilà il y a
des développements pour eux c'est
beaucoup de stress donc is en terme de
de bien-être tous les animau entassés
quels qu'ils soit c'est ça on se donne
rendez-vous dans tous les cas euh devant
le tribunal devant le tribunal bonjour
monsieur parce que la militante écolo il
a un rendez-vous crucial
gracias espagol au revoir bonjour madame
dans quelques minutes la justice rendra
son verdict après une plainte en
diffamation de pur salmon l'entreprise
portée par un fond singapourien basé à
Abu Dhabi entend dénoncer une prise de
parole d'Esther Dufort devant la
Commission européenne et le lancement
d'une pétition en ligne qui a rassemblé
plus de 55000 signatures contre
Luis GIR il y a un petite derrière pour
signer la
pétition c'est un peu David contte
Goliat c'est c'est caricatural mais dans
les fait c'est
ça une condamnation ferait disparaître
l'association d''ester du
fort quelques minutes plus tard
ça marché au secours agissons et relaxé
c'est un soulagement et surtout ça nous
permet de continuer en sachant que tout
ce que l'on dit est valable et on a le
droit de le dire et ça ça fait quand
même une grosse grosse différence quoi
du coup merci merci beaucoup pour le
soutien c'est super fait la force oui
tout à
[Applaudissements]
fait c'est ici au Verdon surmer 100 km
de Bordeaux que l'usine devrait voir le
jour pour le maire Jacques bidalin le
projet est une auben à terme il
permettrait de créer 250 emplois de quoi
redynamiser sa commune aujourd'hui on a
la 64 64 enfants en 2008 il y en avait
100 pratiquement Mme s'il y a que 50
même 100 lo jeement fou qu je veux dire
mais il nous faut des
emplois mais parmi les 1300 habitants
certains
s'inquiètent vous êtes là l'usine sera
là notamment des 3500 m CB d'eau qui
seront rejeté chaque jour dans
l'estuaire de la Gironde station
deuration la station deuration sa
vocation c'est de rendre de l'eau propre
et l'eau qui sera rejetée sera de l'eau
propre moi je prétends que c'est une
vision productiviste qui consiste à
penser que ce qui est moderne c'est de
produire notre nourriture dans des
systèmes de plus en plus artificialisés
aujourd'hui où on est dans ces sociétés
où on se dit qu'il faut retisser le lien
avec la nature et comment on fait contte
tenu de notre puissance destructrice
potentiel pour continuer à vivre en
harmonie soutenez la pêche française
parce que c'est aussi notre ADN aussi en
tant que Français car notre littoral est
cher à tout le monde alors la France est
le premier consommateur de saon en
Europe 250000 tonnes consommées en
moyenne par an importé à 95 % le reste
est produit sur place dans des élevages
que on vient de voir l'aquaculture vous
semble promise à un bel avenir pierre
carleskin c'est une alternative fiable
ah voilà bon voilà une bonne question
non mais d'abord il faut manger du
poisson français du poisson de pêche
français si on veut être utile et je
crois que le reportage que vousz venez
de présenter le montre l'aquaculture ça
peut être une solution ça peut sur
certaines espèces être utiles d'autant
plus qu'il faut pas non plus
complètement nier le fait qu'ils
essayent de faire des progrès sur la
composition de l'alimentation des
poissons d'élevage mais globalement si
vous voulez rendre service à
l'environnement arrêtez de manger du
saumon C saumon d'élevage présenté sous
l'étiquette saumon durable et local vous
font bondir clarnouviant oui pourquoi on
s'est mis à produire du saumon d'élevage
dans des encloss qui sont gigantesques
hein la Norvège est le premier pays
producteur exportateur de saumon c'est
calamiteux ce qui se passe dans les
fiordes en Norvège pourquoi parce que on
a d'abord surexploité les saumons
sauvages et que la pêche commerciale est
allée quasiment au bout de la la logique
quasiment d'extinction de l'espèce dans
le milieu sauvage les stocks s'effondr
voilà c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on
parle du poulet de la mer quand on parle
du saumon qui est en plus pas très bon
comme produit et qu'on retrouve
absolument partout aujourd'hui il y a
pas eu boulangerie qui ne propose pas du
thon ou du saumon on est c'est entre la
peste et le chéra et donc alors qu'avant
c'était un plat de fête le saumon oui
alors le saumon sauvage est excellent
d'ailleurs mais c'est un produit rare
très cher et vu l'état des stocks il
vaut mieux peut-être sans en privé
pendant un temps et en fait on vit très
bien surans ce la question c'est quand
même celle de la consommation est-ce
qu'on a besoin de manger deux fois plus
de poisson comme le disait le reportage
est-ce qu'on a besoin d'avoir des
protéines animales à chaque repas non la
France est la deuxième puissance
maritime au monde pourtant les poissons
que l'on consomme sont majoritairement
importés ou ça pêche sans sans maais
jeot moment donné notre mère qui a été
quand même surexploité depuis de
nombreuses décennies on pourrait presque
dire plusieurs siècles euh a donné son
maximum au niveau mondial autour des
années 90 hein depuis 90 DEP était à 96
1996 on sort plus euh on n'arrive pas à
sortir plus de protéines de la mer
depuis les années 90 malgré le fait
qu'on pêche toujours plus profond plus
loin et de manière plus puissante on
sort pas de protéines supplémentaires
donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
fait appel à l'aquaculture pour venir au
secours entre guillemets de de la
production euh euh de poisson et euh bon
ça c'est quelque chose d'assez euh
courant dans l'histoire de l'humanité
hein dès qu'on arrive plus à tirer de la
nature des choses qu'elle nous donnait
gratuitement et bien on va commencer à
mettre en place des systèmes de
production alors avant de parler des
sujets qui fâchent un mot des habys qui
suscitent beaucoup de de convoitises on
en a beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps
car la Norvège s'apprêtait à ouvrir
l'exploitation minière de ces fonds
marins en Arctique grâce à la pression
d'activiste Camille ettienne en tête la
Norvège a fini par reculer elle va
commencer par explorer ses fonds avant
de se décider ou non à les exploiter
mais que cherche-t-il au juste Raphaël
Itier c'est l'heure du climatoscope sur
la dernière luie de l'humanité
alors qu'est-ce qu'on espère trouver au
fond de au fond des mers ce sont des
métaux pour les batteries de des
voitures ou l'électronique des
téléphones et des ordinateurs car dans
certaines zones euh dans certains fonds
habysau c c ces endroits sont jonchés de
nodules métalliques de la taille d'une
patate euh on voit ça c'est comme un
champ de patate en fait au fond au fond
de l'eau et ils contiennent du cobalt du
nickel et du manganaise qui sont des
métaux intéressants pour la notamment la
transition énergétique alors d'où
viennent ces patates métalliques parce
que c'est un peu bizarre de les voir
joncher comme ça le le sol c'est ça
provient du métal qui s'est accumuler
dans les dans les dans les océans qui
est en non qui est en suspension dans
les océans qui finit par par descendre
s'accumuler et puis il commence à
cristalliser sur un un truc qui traîne
et puis ça ça grossit ça grossit ça
prend des millions d'années puis ça
forme des des des des champs de patates
métalliqu au fond des os alors c'est pas
facile d'accès parce que ça va jusqu'à
6000 6000 m de profondeur et ils ont
déjà imaginé des des robots qui sont des
espèces de motoculteurs téléguidables
depuis la surface et avec un aspirateur
intégré alors ça vient aspirer le fond
ça récupère les patates métalliques ça
les renvoie vers le haut et et et puis
ça renvoie le sédiment qui vient avec et
puis ça fait un énorme panache de de
fumée et ça laisse derrière une espèce
de de champ complètement complètement
labouré et le hic c'est que sur ces
grands fonds il y a tout un écosystème
c'est même on estime le plus vaste de la
planète alors c'est pas un écosystème
luxuriant avec comme une forêt tropicale
ou d'une barrière de corail évidemment
en bas il y a pas de lumière il fait 2
degrés il y a une pression de dingue il
y a pas grand-chose qui pousse c'est du
sable des cailloux mais mais de temps en
temps il y a des créatures un peu
improbables comme des poules pas
oreilles enfin c'est des images assez
saisissantes d'ailleurs des des vers
luminescents ou des des éponges
carnivores c'est en fait un monde pauvre
austère en apparence euh mais on estime
qu'il y a au moins un million d'espèces
qui vivent dans ces endroits-là et dont
on connaitt rien c'est un écosystème qui
est d'une fragilité extrême tout tourne
ralenti là-bas on a trouvé des correaux
âgés de 4000 ans des des éponges
vieilles de 10000 ans tout tout tout
était vraiment extraordinairement stable
immuable et donc très fragile alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on envoie
un motoculteur euh ou une armada de
motoculteur pour venir récupérer des des
des des cailloux au fond bah il y a puis
tout ça ça ça balance un panage enfin ça
change tout et ça ça ça ça ça crée un
grand désordrre alors on s'est posé la
question de savoir ce que ça pouvait
avoir comme impact euh et on est en
train d'essayer de de se rendre compte
de de ça il y a une étude qui a été
faite et qui montre que 26 ans après le
passage d'un motoculteur en fait il y a
rien qui revient les animaux ne sont pas
revenus entre-temps et la conclusion des
scientifiques c'est que des animaux vont
mourir ça c'est une certitude des
espèces vont disparaître avant même
qu'on les connaisse il y a donc d'un
côté des scientifiques et des ONG qui
réclamament un moratoire sur cette
activitélà le temps qu'on fasse le point
sur les impacts possibles et de l'autre
les industriel et quelques pays côtiers
qui sont un peu en embuscade comme la
Norvège vous le mentionniez euh euh tout
à l'heure voilà donc peut-être que ça
serait bien de se poser deux trois
petites questions avant de lancer les
hostilités dans cet endroit qui est
peut-être le seul qui n'a pas été encore
affecté par l'activité humaine alors
tout le monde est d'accord que
l'exploitation des habits c'est une
bombe climatique en puissance parlons
maintenant du chalutage une méthode de
pêche dévastatrice pour les écosystèmes
marins là encore les scientifiques sont
unanimes pour dire qu'il faut en finir
avec le chalutage de fond et créer de
toute urgence des aires marines protégé
digne de ce nom vous leur donnez raison
pierre
carleskin alors vous savez sur ce sujet
du du du chalutage on est aujourd'hui
quand même dans une situation où les
pêches européennes dépendent beaucoup de
cette engin de pêche et si vous regardez
les petits bateaux qui sont derrière moi
il y en a un certain nombre qui
pratiquent le chalu y compris pas très
loin des côtes donc sur ce sujet la
question ce qui se pose qui est devant
nous c'est comment est-ce qu'on fait une
transition vers une pêche moins
impactante comment est-ce qu'on fait en
sorte aussi tout simplement de regarder
si on peut pas changer le chalu alors je
sais que certains ne veulent pas
entendre l'idée même queon puisse
adapter le chalu mais vous avez des des
centres de recherche aujourd'hui qui
sont capables de vous proposer des
solutions où le chalu se relève et donc
il a nettement moins d'impact voir il
touche plus le fond il est légèrement
relevé ou bien des situations où le
chalu peut être sélectif ça aujourd'hui
on sait le faire l'intelligence
artificiel vous permet de le faire donc
si vous voulez nous avons devant nous un
objectif évident qui est de réduire
l'impact de la pêche sur les écosystèmes
est-ce que ça passe par une interdiction
pure et simple de cette technique sans
regarder sa capacité d'évoluer ni
regarder euh les conditions
socio-économiques de son de son
interdiction bien moi la solution que je
choisis et bien elle est de dire allons
voir territoire par territoire usage par
usage écosystème par écosystème ben oui
au cas par cas et sur le terrain je vois
aussi les sourcils clarnouviant sur euh
l'amélioration l'intelligence
artificielle du chalutage de fond ça
fait vraiment des décennies
littéralement que les industriel de la
pêche et leurs alliés politiques
tiennent un discours du cas par cas en
disant vous savez quand on s'est battu
contre la pêche en eau profonde vraiment
les chalu qui passait jusqu'à 2000 m de
profondeur on a gagné en 2016
l'interdiction de cette barbarie
écologique en fait il n'y a toutes les
bonnes raisons de ne pas croire ces
discours et de regarder scientifiquement
factuellement les impacts d'un du
chalutage ne sont pas acceptables ils ne
sont absolument pas acceptables d'un
point de vue de la biodiversité et aussi
d'un point de vue social et économique
et donc la question c'est en effet de
savoir est-ce qu'on est d'accord sur le
bilan et si on est d'accord sur le bilan
alors on prend nos responsabilités et on
se met à piloter l'action publique de
façon à ce qu'il n'y ait aucune casse
sociale dans la transition des pêches
alors justement à propos de casse
sociale le secrétaire d'État à la mer
Barville disait que si on interdisait le
le le chalutage dans les ares marines
protégées et le chalutage de fond sat
tuait la filière ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que effectivement clar nouvient
vous avez initié avec l'association
Bloom un groupe de recherche et vous
avez présenté vos conclusions devant le
Parlement européen et ce qui en ressort
de ce rapport c'est que l'on peut tout à
fait sauver l'océan et les emplois si
l'on s'en donne les moyens euh ce que l'
constate c'est que en résumé hein je
vais pas rentrer dans le détail
évidemment on on fait le le le le
constat que en terme de création de
richesse par tonne débarqué donc je
rentre dans le détail mais c'est le la
valeur ajoutée en fait des navires euh
des flottilles et en terme d'emploi et
bien en fait les les les meilleurs
élèves ce sont les bateaux qui qui sont
équipés en casier en filet et en en
ligne et pas les chalu c'est aussi
plutôt les petits navires enfin même
significativement les petits navires qui
ont un
meilleur ratio du point de vue de la
richesse créée et des emplois créés et
sur la productivité écologique ce qu'on
constate aussi c'est que on a sur les
chaluses de fond hein les plus gros
impacts c'est eux qui vont avoir les
plus gros problèmes en terme d'abrasion
des fonds on comprend assez facilement
les émissions de CO2 et puis la
surexploitation ça dépend un peu de la
taille des flottes et puis les les plus
vertueux bah ce sont les ce qu'on
appelle donc les casiers filets et et
lignes euh qui sont bons sur tous les
indicateurs sauf hein les espèces
sensibles notamment les ctacés et les
oiseaux pour lesquels on sait qu'il y a
une grosse actualité donc c'est pas non
plus à négliger pierre carleskine
j'imagine que vous avez lu forcément ce
un résumé de de de de ce rapport il en
ressort effectivement que le bilan est
calamiteux pour la pêche au chalu et la
pêche industrielle concrètement on fait
un peu l'inverse de ce qu'il faudrait
faire aujourd'hui non bon quel amiteux
je pense que il faudrait être peut-être
apprendre aussi être un tout petit peu
dans la nuance dans la façon de de
parler d'ailleurs le le rapport ne dit
pas calamiteux le rapport il établit
clairement que il est plus rentable
économiquement comme
environnementalement de faire de la
ligne de faire du filet du casier la
question si vous voulez quand on est
politique elle est celle de où on va
parce que l'étude qui a été présentée à
l'instant par arold de Levrel est
extrêmement intéressante mais elle
constitue en quelqu sorte une photo de
l'État instantané or moi si vous voulez
si demain je dois prendre la décision de
faire passer l'ensemble de la flotte de
pêche qui aujourd'hui fa fait du chalu
vers du filet de la ligne et du casier
en côtier en fait je ne sais pas faire
je ne sais pas faire parce que vous
aurez forcément trop de bateaux qui vont
faire du filet en zone côtière trop de
bateaux qui vont faire du casier trop de
bateaux qui vont faire de la ligne et ça
va pas rentrer si je me permets cette
analogie faire du bœuf de cobé tout le
monde sait que environnementalement
c'est plus c'est moins impactant que du
faer du bœuf intensif et ça vous
rapporte plus d'argent simplement vous
n'allez pas convertir l'intégralité des
éleveurs bvin à faire du bœuf de cobé
ben c'est la même chose parce que déjà
vous n'allez pas avir le marché parce
que il y a aussi une question de marché
vous savez la pêche au chalu elle est
aussi en quelque sorte une sorte de
laossature de l'alimentation du marché
de poisson français ce qui me manque
profondément et là aussi je veux
souligner le travail et l'apport de ma
collègue Catherine Chabot c'est et bien
une capacité à développer des scénarios
Catherine le propose à travers la
création d'un IPOs l'équivalent du GEC
des océans c'est-à-dire des
scientifiques qui nous présentaient des
scénarios scénario 1 scénario 2 scénario
3 et comment nous politiques nous
pourrions aller vers ces scénarios de
transition car je vous le dis je ne suis
pas du tout opposé à cette idée de la
transition simplement quelle est la
bonne solution pour ne pas se mettre
tout monde en confrontation sur une zone
côtière qui est déjà bien exploitée et
si vous rajoutez les énergies marines
renouvelables les éoliennes vous voyez
bien que vous avez une petite impasse
quand même sur nos côtes je vous laisse
répondre moi j'entends dans ce discours
toujours un argument qui est de dire
arrêtez tout du jour au lendemain
personne n'a jamais dit ça ce qu'on dit
c'est que ça fait depuis vraiment au
moins le début des années 2000 que les
institutions publiques d'ailleurs
françaises y compris Matignon disent que
le chalutage de fond est une hérésie
environnementale et que en plus il a une
faiblesse structurelle qui est sa
dépendance au gazoil puisqu'il est très
énergivore les travaux de recherche
montrent que la dépendance au gazoil
fait que en gros il y a un énorme
problème de rentabilité et que les
flottes chalutières sont beaucoup moins
rentables que les engins dormants alors
qu'elles sont beaucoup plus subventionné
et y compris les emplois de façon
indirecte un emploi en fait dans la
pêche industrielle y compris les chalues
de fond et cetera c'est un emploi qui
est subventionné à auteur de 60000 € par
an alors qu'un un emploi dans la pêche
artisanale côtière des des ararts
dorments c'estàd des engins qui
impactent moins l'environnement c'est un
emploi qui est subventionné à hauteur de
9 à 14000 € par an et en fait l'ensemble
de de de la photo qu'on a est un est un
ensemble qu'on connaît très bien depuis
vraiment fort longtemps on sait qu'on
doit régler ce problème de d'impact
écologique de non productivité sociale
pour en parler comme ça mais en gros on
est quand même sur des flottes chalutiè
qui produisent deux à trois fois moins
d'emplois que les flottes artisanales on
sait d'où on vient on vient d'une
calamité maintenant ça mettons un cap
pour commencer à construire ensemble des
scénarios et les scénarios c'est la
l'étape d'après c'estàdire que nous on
dit pas on dit on a le constat on a le
cap on connaît les impératifs
écologiques on sait que l'océan est le
est est le poumon bleu de la planète on
a besoin qu'il soit fonctionnel pour
pouvoir absorber du CO2 on sait que
l'état de la biodiversité marine et que
les l'état de dégradation des fondmins
est extrême en Europe et donc on a
besoin d'aller vers ce cap comment on va
y aller ça c'est l'objet de la
coconstruction qui s'ouvre et c'est la
page qui s'ouvre à partir de alors
justement pierre carkine comment on va y
aller alors voilà moi moi si vous voulez
j'ai j'ai une question dans tout ça
c'est que comment est-ce que je m'assure
que la la la somme de poisson qui est
pêché par cette filière chalutière et
bien nous pouvons la pêcher aussi avec
les autres techniques de pêche parce que
là est toute la question si demain vous
vous retrouvez dans une situation où
vous interdisez un type de pêche dans
les eaux européennes et que vous n'êtes
pas capable en fait fait de avec les
autres techniques de pêche d'aller
chercher ce poisson qu'est-ce qui va se
passer vous avez un vide sur le marché
or le marché il a horur de ville le
consommateur il va aller voir ailleurs
et on va en fait et bien acheter plus de
poisson importés on va importer du
poisson du reste du monde or le reste du
monde désolé de le dire il est pas
vraiment beaucoup plus vertuueux que
nous pour l'instant onorte 95 % not
consommation de poisson hein 70 % on
importe 70 % de notre consommation de
poisson c'est pas une raison pour le
augmenter donc vous allez vous retrouver
encore plus
dépendant pour de la réflexion la
réflexion justement des travaux c'est
vraiment de de réfléchir à volume
constant et de savoir est-ce qu'on peut
améliorer en faisant justement des des
des transitions moi je suis je je suis
vraiment très très contente de de ces
travaux je veux le dire on a
suffisamment l'occasion de se disputer
avec les anouviant et avec Bloom moi je
trouve que ces travaux sont extrêmement
utiles parce qu'il permettent et bien de
mettre des données objectives mais il
faut bien mettre en avant l'ensemble des
données du pro problème et moi je serais
très heureux de pouvoir continuer à
réfléchir sur voilà ces scénarios à à
établir et je ne peux que vous
encourager à à pouvoir nous les proposer
d'autant que c'est indispensable les
études montrent que plus on protège les
air marines plus les stocks sont
importants plus les tonnag de poisson
double quasiment donc en fait tout le
monde est gagnant à Levrel oui alors
vous avez raison de rappeler ça c'est un
un élément qui aujourd'hui enfin qui est
bien connu des scientifiques les études
le prouvent systématiquement quand on
laisse se reposer la nature elle devient
plus productive pour revenir sur la
question de la transition la transition
c'est toujours un sujet hyper complexe
parce qu'on parle d'un quotidien de
milliers de personnes qui vont devoir en
fait s'inventer une nouvelle vie
professionnelle et c'est pas trivial
hein quand on a 20 ans d'activité dans
un domaine pour autant il y a des choses
qu'on sait quand même faire aujourd'hui
qui poserait pas des des des défis
énormes par exemple la langoustine on
sait la pêcher au chalu ou on sait la
pêcher au casier c'est très facile entre
guillemets encore une fois hein je je
simplifie mais c'est quand même très
facile de pouvoir imaginer euh
aujourd'hui avoir une pêche à la
langoustine uniquement au casier on a un
autre exemple le bar on peut le pêcher
au chalu ù on peut le pêcher à la ligne
au chalu c'est un un poisson qui arrive
tout assez qui qui qui a pas du tout la
même saveur que le barre de ligne euh on
va le vendre pas moins cher certes parce
qu'on a un meilleur rendement mais voilà
c'est à un moment donné c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on veut en fait comme produit de la
mer dans nos assiettes quelle est la
fréquence de la consommation et ça ces
deux exemples que je je viens d'évoquer
ils sont assez concrets est assez facile
à imaginer sans fausse démagogie et
j'ajouterai un dernier élément par
rapport à ça c'est que les subventions
aujourd'hui bénéficie principalement que
soit en tonnage débarqué que ce soit en
terme de rentabilité quels que soient
les indicateurs qu'on utilise pour les
grands Chalus de fond aussi pélagique
mais principalement de fond et ça ça
pose question parce que justement
justement c'est la question que jeis
poser à Pierre
klskin il ne faudrait pas mieux flécher
ces subventions les les redistribuer
plutôt selon l'utilité social des
navires voir sous conditions de
durabilité oui alors aujourd'hui quand
même on a adopté un Fond européen pour
les affaires maritimes la pêche et
l'aquaculture qui n'est pas un un
instrument qu'on
distribue de façon proportionnelle à la
quantité de poisson pêchés par les
différents bateau pierre kskin moins de
20 % des subventions à la pêche versé en
France au cours des dernières années ont
financé des activités à caractère
durable selon les chires officiels moi
je je me sens plutôt aller sur le sujet
puisque dans la négociation avec les
États-membres que nous avons eu sur le
le ce fameux féempa dont je viens de
parler donc ce Fond européen nous avions
voulu consacrer ça c'était la position
du Parlement européen 25 % de ce fond
sur les opérations relatives à la
protection de la biodiversité
malheureusement dans la négociation avec
les États-membres ceux-ci ont été
absolument inflexibles et ont demandé à
ce que ce soit réduit à 10% donc si vous
voulez à un moment moi je porte un
certain nombre de positions euh c'est
pas pas pas responsable du fait que
c'est pas celles qui finalement sont
adopté par la majorité en tout cas dans
la négociation européenne ne sont pas
retenu et et par ailleurs très vite
parce qu' on est très en retard il y a
des subventions qui vont vers des
monstres marins Bloom votre association
clin nouvien a montré qu'il y avait des
chalutiers géants dans les eaux
françaises et les air marines protégées
par ailleurs le plus grand chalutier
pélagique du monde 145 m de long un
monstre je ne sais pas si on peut le
voir arrive en France vous confirmez
tout à fait alors j'ai lu la presse
comme tout le monde j'ai vu
effectivement qu'il allait arriver alors
moi je vous avoue que ça me laisse plus
que perplexe parce qu'en plus ayant eu
en charge la gestion des ports bretons
pendant quelques années je sais une
chose c'est que ce bateau de ne rentre
pas dans le port de saint-malot donc en
fait il va pêcher mais vous savez qu' va
être acheté pierre carleskin il va être
racheté par la compagnie des pêches de
Saint-Malo alors il ne rentre peut-être
pas dans le port mais en tout cas il va
c'est c'est bien ça mon problème c'est
que il rentre pas dans le port donc en
fait il va aller pêcher potentiellement
dans les eaux françaises il va avoir son
activité à bord et en fait il va
débarquer probablement à myen qui est
d'ailleurs déjà son port d'attache euh
au au au Pays-Bas moi je vois
franchement pas l'intérêt euh de voir
arriver ce genre de navire de pêche dans
la flotte française alors beaucoup va
dire euh le gouvernement autorise ce
genre de transaction comme monsieur
carleskind est un député de la majorité
présidentielle je pense que c'est une
bonne idée de s'opposer à cette
transaction parce qu'elle est autorisée
par l'administration et euh c'est un
remplacement d'un autre navire de 90 m
pour faire du surimi industriel peut-on
vivre sans surimi industriel la réponse
est oui il se trouve que Monsieur
carleskin comme il précise on on est
souvent en chamaillerie tous les deux
parce que il l' voté pas plus tard que
le 18 janvier pour continuer à permettre
d'autoriser ces immenses navires
chalutiers pélagiqu pélagique de fond
d'ailleurs ça peut être du pélagique ou
alors ceux qui racle les fonds alors
qu'on avait une proposition d'un rapport
d'initiative au Parlement européen qui
était voté le 18 janvier et qui
permettait de se positionner contre ces
navires industriels et la question des
navires de plus de 25 m qui rentrent
dans les eaux françaisise et qui rentre
en concurrence directe avec les pêcheurs
français c'est exactement le cœur du
débat de cette histoire de la transition
alors la transition on peut toujours
dire on va la faire un jour ce serait
quand même bien de commencer par
interdire ces bateaux qui prennent en
volume ce que des milliers de petits
pêcheurs peuvent prendre au quotidien et
si on veut redynamiser notre littoral
notre économie leur donner juste vous
savez ce que c'est en fait le problème
de la pêche artisanale en vrai c'est de
l'accès à du cota et de l'accès à des
zones de pêche or C ces monstres marins
qui viennent à 3000 des côtes mais
pêcher à vraiment au nez à la barbe des
pêcheurs côtiers c'est une grande
provocation donc monsieur carleskin on
on va continuer à se voir au Parlement
européen à avoir des échanges un petit
peu verts parce que je sais que les
éléments de langage quand on est dans
les médias tout va bien parce que là on
est on est dans des généralités quand on
rentre dans le concret de vos votes vous
n'êtes pas pas du tout au rendez-vous
donc j'aimerais bien comprendre pourquoi
vous ne vous opposez pas à la présence
de ces navires industriels dans les EAU
français si vous dites être en faveur de
la pêche côtière française peut-être
parce qu'il y a une différence entre 25
m et 145 m parce Queen fait quand vous
dites 25 m mais vous vous attaquez à une
partie de la flotte de pêche européenne
qui n'est pas forcément que faite de
bateau industriel donc moi je trouve
regrettable que vous essayez de balayer
d'un revers de main ensemble de la
pêcherie européenne en essayant de
mettre dans le même panier les bateaux
de 25 m et 1 m monsieur kkin quand vous
dites ça en fait vous avez abattu vos
cartes parce que vous savez très bien
que les statistiques sont formelles 97 %
des flottes de la flotte française est
composée de bateaux qui font moins de 25
m donc quand vous dites vous voulez
balayer d'un rever deain la flotte
industrielle européenne non c'est pas
vrai on veut justement s'attaquer au 1 à
3 % en Allemagne c'est 1 % des navires
en France c'est 3 % des navires et ce
sont des bateaux qui vont capturer
jusqu'à quasiment la moitié des
débarquements donc on est sur un pur
problème d'injustice sociale vous êtes
dans le dénis scientifique et vous êtes
en train de nous dire que quand il faut
faire transitionner 3 % de la flotte
française des plus destructeur
socialement et écologiquement vous
n'êtes pas au rendez-vous voilà ce que
ça nous dit et c'est parfaitement clair
donc en effet dans le prochain Parlement
si vous êtes réélu on aura beaucoup de
travail à faire parce qu'il faudra
commencer par le constat je trouve
regrettable que vous n'ayez pas beaucoup
de nuances et vous soz com capable de
comprendre qu'entre 25 et 145 il y a
énormément différen les pêcheurs
français les pêcheurs français le comité
régional des pêches de Normandie demande
l'interdiction des bateaux de plus de 25
m bon on n'arrivera pas à vous
réconcilier aujourd'hui sans transition
cette question néanmoins peut-on réparer
ce que l'homme a détruit au moins en
partie c'est ce que s force de faire une
entreprise montpélieren qui repople les
océans et restaure la biodiversité dans
les ports français depuis 2015 elle a
relâché plus de 17000 poissons en
Méditerranée rien que ça le monde de
demain commence aujourd'hui et c'est
signé Emma guiso et bar
Abar sur le Grand port maritime de
Marseille se trouve une entreprise qui
repeuple la
mer ces drôles de CAG sont ce qu'ils
appellent des biout des refuges pour les
jeunes poissons Anthony Fortin le
technicien aquacole d'cocéan s'occupe de
les installé en mer dans les zones
côtières dégradé par l'homme hop je vais
mettre comme ça
on a beaucoup bétonné dans des zones
portuaires comme j'ai derrière moi on va
avoir des Diges avec des très gros blocs
on va avoir des Cais lisses en béton
évidemment les espèces vont pas pouvoir
se trouver d'habitat et vont pas pouvoir
se cacher on y voit plein de gros
poissons mais au final ces gros poissons
vont manger les petits et évidemment
sans les sans les petits il y aura pas
de gros donc ce que j'ai ici à côté de
moi ce sont des biotes ce sont
l'équivalent des maisons insectes mais
pour les milieux aquatiques c'est là
qu'on va avoir les les poissons les
jeunes poissons qui vont venir autour
graviter se nourrir de ce qui va se
développer dans dans les coquilles
d'hître et se protéger des prédateurs
dans cet espace ici de gris qui est qui
est donc en
façade car une fois pondu par leurs
géniteurs en pleine mer ces larves de
poisson sont à la mercie des
prédateurs et seul 1 % d'entre elles
trouvent leur chemin jusqu'aux côtes
pour s'y abriter pendant leur
croissance sans ces habitats marins
artificiels aucune ne
survivrait il y aurait 100 % de
perte
suspendu par des chaînes ou sanglé
autour de poteau ces biohut sont
aujourd'hui installés dans une trentaine
de ports en France et Anthony s'assure
que les larves de poisson et le git et
le couvert c'est un bi qui est à l'eau
depuis 2 ans environ donc là on voit
qu'on a une petite algue primaire on a
ici par exemple un petit nudi branche
qui se balade ici donc toute cette faune
cette Flor se sont se sont développé sur
sur ces gris et vont apporter donc la
fonction nourricière au jeunes
poissons la société A dévelppé un autre
système plus efficace pour cette fois-ci
essayer de sauver ces plus de 90 % de
larbe de poisson dévoré par les
prédateur éocéan fait capturer ses
juvéniles de quelques millimètres de
long par des pêcheurs du coin pour les
élever à l'abri dans de petits bassins
pendant plusieurs
mois c'est Damien argex le chef
biologiste qui s'assure de la bonne
santé de ces nouveaux
arrivants donc la première phase qu'on
va avoir nous c'est les acclimater les
trier identifier mais aussi de savoir si
les post Lares ou Larv sont capables de
bien se nourrir on les place justement
dans ces aquariums là comme ça on garde
un visuel parce que c'est une phase qui
est critique pour nous cette phase
d'acclimatation c'est voilà c'est c'est
des animaux qui sont fragiles qui qui
sont
stressés le taux de survie des bébés
poissons accueillliis dans leur
laboratoire est de 80
% une fois les 3 cm atteints ils sont
introduits dans des bassins occultants
pour éviter tout contact avec les
humains c'est très simple de domestiquer
un poisson ou en tout cas on a des
espèces qui sont curieuses donc qui vont
instinctivement venir voir nous on veut
pas ça on veut que au final quand on les
repup les animaux quand ils regardent la
grande bleue bah ils fusionnent avec des
espèces qui sont restées dans le milieu
qu'on narrive pas à dissocier qui est
issu de l'affaire mais qui est resté
dans le milieu et surtout que voilà il y
a un comportement qui soit totalement
préservé inné de de chasse et et de
comportement social avec avec d'autres
espèces ça permet justement bah dès
qu'il y a un prédateur de se dire ou là
il y a un prédateur BIM je m'en vais
alors que s'il y a déjà un lien avec
avec l'homme bah on peut avoir une
modification du comportement et donc ça
on veut pas du
tout au bout de 6 mois ces poissons
mesurent 7 cm et sont enfin suffisamment
développés pour survivre en milieu
naturel ils sont alors relâchés en mer
exactement là où ils avaient été
capturés
il s'agit de restaurer l'écosystème
marin et les stocks de poissons pour la
pêche depuis sa création en 2015
echocéan a réinttroduit environ 20000
poissons une façon de rendre à la
Méditerranée une infime partie de ce
qu'elle nous donne depuis des
[Musique]
millénaires alors ce reportage montre
qu'on a des solutions à porter deain que
pourraitt-on faire autrement augmenter
la taille des filets notamment euh je
pense que oui il y a un peu de
perplexité autour de cette idée de de
pourquoi pas hein d'accélérer la
restauration de la nature mais c'est
toujours un petit peu bizarre de se dire
qu'on va mettre en place des solutions
financiarisées finalement de
repeuplement alors que simultanément on
ne protège même pas puisque vous avez
mentionné en passant que les air-marines
protégé en France ne sont pas du tout
protégé et que le chalutage de fond y
est encore euh autorisé euh avec des
votes dont on n pas parl et qui ont
généré un peu le les les altercations
qu'on peut avoir avec Pierre carleskine
puisqu'on est en désaccord très profond
là-dessus donc le le gouvernement
français se refuse à faire l'évidence au
niveau international et à même suivre
les avis de la Commission européenne
d'interdir le chalutage de fond et à
côté de ça on repeuple c'est c'est c'est
un petit peu bizarre pierre carleskine
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour
effectivement protéger les aires marines
euh alors qu'aujourd'hui la la
protection stricte ne concerne que je
crois 0,5 % de notre territoire maritime
à peine non alors clairire nouviant dit
qu'on a un desésaccord profond moi je
suis pas du tout d'accord moi je suis
parfaitement d'accord pour interdire le
chalu de fond sur les espèces de fond
sensibles sur les pardon pas les espèces
sur les habitats de fond qui sont qui
sont
sensibles le vote qu'il oui dans les air
marines vous avez voté contre le 18
janvier mais j'ai voté contre d'ailleurs
comme vos collègues du groupe des
sociau-démocrates qui globalement ont
refusé
l'interdiction donc les socio-démocrates
globalement on voter contre la
proposition qui était d'interdire
globalement dans toutes les aires
marines protégé le chalgutage de fond
pour dire quoi pour dire ce que j'ai dit
au début de l'émission dire allons-y au
cas par cas pierre carleskin les
scientifiques ne parlent pas du cas par
cas mais de la nécessité de protéger 30
% des air marines 30 % pas du cas par
cas qu'est-ce que vous répondez aux
scientifiques alors là je je ne vous
rejoins pas je ne vous rejoins pas parce
que les scientifiques disent bien il
faut protéger 30 % après au sein de ces
30% les mesures précises de conservation
elles doivent correspondre à ce que vous
cherchez à protéger et c'est pour
ça vous devez avoir des objectifs vous
devez avoir des objectifs concrets de
protection mais
quand vous allez contre la diplomatie
internationale c'est très difficile je
comprends
vre des bate de pêche que vous proposez
de mettre à l'arrêt pouroi parce qu'il
vont pêcher dans le parc marin d'Ise et
que aujourd'hui il pratique des engins
de fond dans le parc
marin
sonéêenditise où il est possible de
pêcher parce que le fond ne présente pas
un enjeu de sensibilité particulièrement
important par contre
dans chement vous dites n'orte quoi je
vois pas pourquoi vous dites n'importe
quoi aujourd'hui dans le parc maradir
West il y a des endroits qui ne sont pas
ultra vous rendez compte de ce que vous
dites c'est incroyable de dire que par
Mar n' pas d'enjeu de protection des
fond mais bien sûr que si mais pas dans
l'intégralité du parc marin d'Ise
poursuivons cette conversation au
Parlement européen avec plaisir non mais
moi je préfère le faire sur le terrain
parce que les discussions dans les
salons
Paris à R de nous faire une émission
spéciale de plusieurs heures avec joie
avec joie en tout cas impossible de se
quitter sans donner la parole à celles
qui se démènent pour que notre avenir
soit vivable Camille Etienne a réussi à
infléchir la position de la Norvège sur
l'exploitation de ses abis entre deux
combats elle a tenu à nous dire ça c'est
l'heure de sa carte verte Camille nous
sommes tout
oui la technologie ne nous sauvera pas
pour une fois je céderai pas aux
formules littéraires comme j'aime
habituellement le faire plutôt
laissez-moi vous le démontrer de manière
mathématique pour TER de convaincre les
plus rationnels d'entre vous
accordez-moi une formule tout de même
celle du navigateur Éric tabarli l'océan
c'est ce qu'on a dans le dos quand on va
à la plage pendant très longtemps je
n'ai pas pensé à l'océan ou du moins j'y
pensais peu il avait le goût de vacances
et la couleur des cartes postales un
légé en brin qui accompagnait nos
enfances de loin un temps décor qui
apaise les chagrins et qui rend
cinématographique la solitude je me
sentais mal à l'aise dans ses bras comme
un vertige à l'envers ces Abys
mystérieux dont j'avais peur qu'il
m'avale comme on a peur du monstre sous
son lit cet horizon brouillé des
courants qui nous rend si vulnérable
parce qu'alors rien ne peut s'y prévoir
tout peut y surgir et puis ce silence
sourd qui ne nous laisse d'autre choix
que d'écouter ce qui nous arrange
habituellement de ne pas entendre nous
entretenons avec l'océan un rapport
principalement poétique rarement
politique l'océan notre part d'ombre
l'angle mort de nos marches de nos
soulèvements de nos colères on lui
tourne le dos pour aller dorer sur nos
serviettes et cette distance rend la
guerre qui s'y déroule
invisible vous me direz ce ne sera pas
la première je parle de guerre à dessin
parce qu'on a déclaré la guerre aux
poissons ce n'est pas moi qui ai été
séduite par la rhétorique de la phrase
pour faire dans l'air du temps c'est
Daniel poli spécialiste mondial des
ressources source marine on a déclaré la
guerre au poissons d'ailleurs la pêche
industrielle vient de là GPS sonard
acoustique on utilise des technologies
qu'on a inventé pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et qu'on applique contre
les poissons c'est comme pour les arbres
si on en coupe plus vite qu'il n'en
repousse on finit par se retrouver sur
un sol désert alors les scientifiques
ont établi un seuil maximal au-del de
celui-ci il y a plus de poissons pêchés
que de poissons qui naissent donc
mathématiquement on court à leur
disparition
plus d'un tiers des espèces de poissons
sont pêché au-delà de ce seuil et 100 %
frôlent la limite de ce seuil il y en
aura plus c'est mathématique on vide
littéralement l'océan de sa vie c'est
mathématique voyez vous-même dans les
années 90 on atteint un pic à l'époque
130 millions de tonnes de poissons
étaient pêchés par an depuis nous ne
vivons qu'un inéluctable déclin la
surenchère technologique a beau
sa'afférer les immenses filets des
chalues ont beau raclé les fant sur des
kilomètr pour tout attraper on a beau
inventer de nouvelles machines pour
pêcher plus profond plus loin des côtes
attraper à l'aide de nos bateaux usines
qui sont bientôt trop grand pour entrer
dans les porort de nouvelles espèces qui
avaient jusque-l été épargné de notre
envie de les avaler nous devons nous y
résoudre nous avons atteint les limites
de ce que la nature peut nous donner ou
de ce qu'on peut lui prendre la pêche
est la première activité humaine à
atteindre un plafond la surenchère
technologique ne permet pas de compenser
l'effondrement des ressources une sacrée
leçon qui nous tape dans l'épaule
puisqu'on a gardé l'océan dans le dos
alors on pourrait s'arrêter être
raisonnable plutôt quand nos eaux
occidentales sont quasiment vides on y
est nous allons piller dans les eaux du
Sud le port de l'Orient se met à
emporter du poisson Domane on pille à
tel point que certains pays comme le
Sénégal n'ont presque plus de poisson
pour leurs habitants on a tout prix pour
en faire des sourisis ou de la farine de
petits poissons pour les élevages de
saumon cette course à la technologie à
un coup de plus en en plus élevé alors
on coupe les coups là où on peut les cas
d'esclavage sont de plus en plus
fréquents comme dans la pêche auon de
Carrefour comme le dévoile l'ONG Bloom
et c'est un choix un choix politique la
pêche artisanale qui nourrit beaucoup
mieux le monde tout en ne surexploitant
pas les ressources et la première à en
pâtir un pêcheur industriel reçoit en
moyenne 187 fois plus de subventions au
gasoil par an qu'un pêcheur artisanal
pourtant il y a une solution pour une
fois efficace et les mardes la meilleure
chose à faire ce serait de faire moins
de se retourner et de voir qu'il suffit
de ne pas alimenter cette guerre pour
qu'elle cesse soudainement la paix dans
l'océan est à une portée de courage
celui de déposer les armes et en
l'occurrence la plus dangereuse d'entre
elles elle s'appelle la pêche
industrielle pierre
carleskine le monde a déclaré la guerre
au poisson comme le dit Camille Étienne
écoutez il y a une chose qui est sûre
c'est que s'il y a une partie du poisson
qu'il faut renoncer à manger c'est le
poisson d'importation parce que comme
vous l'avez fort bien dit on va piller
chez les autres vous vous rendez compte
que si vous enlevez le poisson
d'importation vous divisez par tris
votre consommation de poisson c'est à
peu prèsque d'idier gasqel suggérer en
terme de réduction de la consommation
donc manger du poisson français arrêtez
de manger du poisson d'importation un
dernier mot dire aux armateurs au
chalutiers aux pêcheurs vous n'êtes pas
les rois de la mer vous êtes des acteurs
du milieu mais pas les propriétaires d'
un bien commun essayons de construire
ensemble une filière durable est-ce que
c'est si difficile pierre carleskine ah
ben c'est compliqué quand vous êtes face
à des gens qui ont investi beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup d'eux même beaucoup de
leur vie parce que parfois vous avez des
pêcheurs artisans qui se sont endettés à
hauteur de 3 million d'euros pour
acheter un navire de 18 m par exemple
donc ce sont typiquement ce genre de
personnes à qui vous êtes obligé de dire
ben du moins vous pouvez pas leur dire
jour lendemain vous allez arrêter vous
allez é changer donc effectivement on a
un éorme travail sur comment est-ce
qu'on fait la transition donc la suite
de l'étude proposée par Bloom sera
extrêmement utile et nécessaire surtout
merci à tous les trois avant de se
quitter quelques recommandations de
lecture à commencer par la pêche
écologie de di gasquel aux éditions CA
du même auteur cette fois aux éditions
Acte Sud pour une révolution dans la
mer ce livre océan chez la relève et la
peste une infographie de la mre
extrêmement bien faite aux éditions du
CNRS et ce livre de Jean-Baptiste
fressau sans transition don vous vouliez
nous parler CLA nousvons oui je pense
c'est mon coup de cœur en ce moment
c'est parce que ce chercheur de du CNRS
a reconstruit en fait l'histoire des
énergies et il montre qu'il n'y a jamais
eu de transition énergétique on a cumulé
en fait toutes les énergies au lieu de
les remplacé le bois n'a pas remplacé le
charbon le charbon n'a pas remplacé le
pétrole et cetera ils se sont cumulés
pour nous donner plus de confort une
matérialité incroyablement infinie dans
des limites planétaires qui elles sont
bien finies et donc le l'enjeu de la
transition il est très complexe et il
passe nécessairement par une refonte de
notre pensée économique pour se dire
est-ce que on peut passer d'une économie
qui est aujourd'hui basée sur des désirs
à une économie qui est basée sur des
besoins c'est à lire donc on se quitte
sur ces mots je vous retrouve le mois
prochain pour une nouvelle émission
consacrée cette fois au déchets une
émission qui ne sera pas à
[Musique]
jeté